The houses you see around you are all solar houses.
I don't know if you know that.
But did you notice?
The goal is to make, have electric, solar roofs...
...that look better than a normal roof,...
...generate electricity lasts longer, have better insulation,...
...and actually have an installed cost...
...that is less than a normal roof plus the cost of electricity.
So we're gonna show you the system before shot of that house.
Over there.
Now, that's all solar.
If you look carefully, you can see the solar cells.
So that house is also solar...
...and that's a sort of a style of a French slate,...
...which is one of the hardest things to produce.
This is what the French slate hydrographic looks like.
You can see that.
The third house is really transformative.
From the vantage point of this tree, it looks completely opaque,...
...but as the angle changes, it goes from transparent to opaque.
To the sun, it's transparent.
The most surprising one is the Tuscan glass.
All of the dark tiles have solar panels.
From the sun's vantage point, which has to be the high angle,...
...you can see the solar cells,...
...but as you change the angle to a shallow angle,...
...it reverts to a sort of an orangey color.
One of the advantages of glass...
...is that we can actually make it a lot tougher...
...and last a lot longer than a conventional roof.
We want to look better, last longer, provide better insulation...
...and cost less, all things considered, than a conventional roof.
And I think taking this approach, it can be.
That's where we're headed and I hope you agree that's the future we want.